llegó por última vez a nuestro sistema
solar hace 50.000 años El Cometa C 2022
e3ztf se está acercando al planeta
Tierra También conocido como El Cometa
verde fue recientemente descubierto en
la órbita de Júpiter se acercó al sol en
enero y desde Entonces comenzó a
dirigirse a nuestro vecindario
tiene varios kilómetros de diámetro es
absolutamente minúsculo como un pequeño
asteroide congelado una bola de nieve
sucia que se encuentra a 42 millones de
kilómetros Así que es minúsculo No
veremos el cometa en sí lo que podemos
ver Es lo que ocurre a su alrededor la
desgasificación que puede extenderse a
lo largo de millones de kilómetros es
por eso que el Cometa se hace visible
es de color verde debido a las moléculas
de carbono diatómico que al desprenderse
del núcleo del Cometa terminan
desintegradas por Los Rayos UV del Sol
una reacción que produce luz verde sin
embargo El Cometa no será visible sin un
cielo despejado y poca contaminación
lumínica estará en su punto más cercano
a la tierra el primero de febrero y con
el regreso de la luna al cielo nocturno
el 25 de enero El Cometa verde será más
visible en mitad de la noche una vez que
la luna se haya puesto